[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a short drama film
called the carmen lane
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the protagonist of the movie is a
middle-aged housewife named sarah she
lives with her teenage daughter carly
and her husband dave one afternoon sarah
is in a delightful mood she is blasting
a romantic song on the radio and is
dancing around the house at the same
time carly returns home from school and
is in a seemingly bad mood she takes off
her dirty shoes and carelessly tosses
them away her mother tries to lighten
her mood by dancing and singing around
her but she doesn't acknowledge it and
rather finds it annoying sarah follows
her to the kitchen while still dancing
but carly simply turns the radio's
volume down and takes the dinner plate
from the counter it is evident that
carly doesn't appreciate her mother's
efforts and takes her for granted sarah
however doesn't seem to mind her
daughter's indifference she simply turns
the volume back up and checks carly's
bag to see if she has eaten all of her
food sarah then finds a test paper
inside her bag that has very bad grades
although it is only a mock test she
urges her daughter to do better carly
again ignores her which has become sort
of a routine in the household when sarah
asks for an answer she simply walks away
to her room moments later sarah picks up
her drink from the living room's coffee
table but it drops from her hand she
starts to panic and yells for help as
her feet begin to move on their own
carly hears her cry and quickly runs
downstairs to see her mother is
levitating off of the ground she is too
stunned to speak in the following scene
three men are trying to bring sarah back
to the ground one of them is her husband
dave he holds her hand for emotional
support as the other two guys pull sarah
down they try their best but do not
succeed it is almost as if they are
working against a mysterious force that
is keeping her afloat maybe an angry
harry potter is lurking around the
corner no matter how much they try she
doesn't budge from her place carly
watches them from the door not being
able to comprehend what is going on the
men leave a while later but sarah keeps
levitating dave then calls their family
doctor dr behringer to inspect the
situation he measures the distance she
has elevated from the ground and finds
out that she is going higher over time
this worries the entire family even the
doctor does not have an answer as to how
it is possible he simply takes her blood
sample to study it and hopefully find
out why gravity has stopped working on
her he also promises to send in a
consultant dr benham who can potentially
help her the husband asks him how long
it will take but the doctor assures them
that since sarah is healthy there is
every reason to believe she will be
better in no time starting that day
sarah cannot move around and keeps on
flying upwards in only one day she
stands taller than her husband dave buys
a bedpan to help her defecate a real
sign of true love but their hopes of her
getting better are fading with time
since she cannot move from the room the
father and daughter redecorate it to fit
her needs and keep her entertained soon
sarah's sisters also come to her house
to help her with life it is almost as if
she is bedridden and needs people to
take care of her they clean up after her
every day eventually they start needing
a ladder to reach her dr barringer
visits regularly to check up on sarah
and measure how much she has elevated
since the last time he keeps track of
the math and finds out that she is being
pulled up at a higher rate as time
passes by to stop this he makes her wear
a belt with weights inside of it so the
weights would decrease the rate of
elevation however this doesn't help
sarah's case and she almost reaches the
ceiling dave starts getting frustrated
seeing no results out of the doctor's
experiments at night sarah starts
wrapping a blanket around herself while
sleeping on air dave loves his wife
dearly and makes sure to be with her all
the time he has shifted from the bedroom
to the living room to be with her at
night just in case she needs anything
sarah's consultant dr mary benham only
arrives after a week by this time sarah
is up on the ceiling struggling to go
further up the doctor introduces herself
and reaches out to shake her hand she
apologizes for not getting there sooner
and inquires how they are coping with
the situation dave jokes and says that
the ceiling is not a convenient place to
keep a wife at least dave didn't make a
joke about the kitchen for some reason
the doctor doesn't seem to be surprised
by sarah's condition she simply brings
out a measuring tape and measures the
distance between her and the floor dave
offers the doctor a cup of tea and sends
carly to make it without sarah's help
the kitchen is a complete mess carly
brings out a dirty mug from the sink and
simply rinses it before pouring tea in
it and handing it to the doctor carly is
that lazy roommate that we have all had
before after realizing the severeness of
sarah's condition the doctor's demeanor
changes the family had been waiting for
her to come and miraculously cure sarah
but they soon realized that she too has
no idea what the problem is the doctor
bluntly tells the family that their case
is unique so nothing is certain from
what the doctors have seen and studied
sarah will continue to move upwards at a
variable but increasing rate dave
hesitantly asks the doctor if she can
bring sarah down to which she apologizes
and says she can't the weights will slow
her progress but if she carries more of
it it will injure her their best bet is
to wait for the condition to go away on
its own
in about 10 weeks sarah will reach a
height of 12 000 feet from there she
will need oxygen to survive even after
that she will still keep rising upwards
and they will have to keep her warm and
control her diet sarah finally comes to
the conclusion that she cannot be saved
the family also acknowledges she is
going to rise to the sky until her
inevitable death carly comments that her
mother is going into orbit dave loses
patience and demands that the doctor do
something but she says she can only do
her best to keep her comfortable as
there is no known way to save her that
night dave cuts the ceiling around
sarah's head to allow her to fly up he
is aggressive while cutting it and
almost hurts her careful dave wouldn't
want to accidentally bump her as you're
busy sending her into orbit as the dust
falls on the poor woman she calls for
her daughter to help however she has
forgotten carly is entirely useless she
entirely ignores her mother's pleas and
turns the tap on to not hear her
eventually dave completes making the
hole and holds his wife's hand
sarah's head is now inside carly's room
she is clearly bothered by her mother
invading her privacy even though she has
no control over it the following day
carly is studying for her final exams as
sarah watches her in silence she has to
pee but doesn't want to disturb her
daughter some time later she apologizes
and asks carly to call her father carly
simply brings the bedpan and helps her
following that she sits back to study
but cannot focus with her mother in the
room carly tells her that she cannot
take the exams this year because of the
situation but sarah lashes out at her
she doesn't want to be a drawback in her
daughter's life some days later is dave
and sarah's anniversary they have
invited sarah's sister to dress her up
for the occasion dave compliments her
saying that she looks like an angel and
the two laugh at the irony even at the
time of crisis the couple celebrates and
drinks together dave gets on a table and
kisses her eventually the two have
intercourse when carly returns home from
school one day she hears her mother
moaning in pain it turns out that dave
has tied her leg to the ground to keep
her from flying away which is really
painful for her he sits at the door
unable to watch his wife whimper in
misery carly quickly runs upstairs and
gets a knife to cut the rope in the
following scene sarah has reached
outside the house dave and carly reach
her using a crane to hand her food and
supplies this is probably the last time
they are going to see her so they pack
her with enough food oxygen and water
for her journey to the sky carly hands
her a phone and a battery to call home
when needed she has also brought a music
player so sarah can listen to all of her
favorite songs when she gets bored
following that she is made to wear a
heavy backpack so she would elevate at a
slower speed as the daughter hands her
the rations dave stays quiet and only
watches them before leaving he hugs his
wife tightly knowing that she is never
coming back the family shares a tearful
goodbye the next day we see sarah way
high up in the sky she is hardly visible
from the ground to pass time she is
invested in a crossword puzzle suddenly
a drop of water falls on her book as she
wipes it away it starts to drizzle she
takes off her hat and wears the hood of
her jacket to keep warm some more days
later sarah uses binoculars to look down
at the earth she brings out a packet of
biscuits that carly had given her and
sees that she is almost out of them she
calls carly and asks her what she is
cooking for herself without her mother
she has started to eat baked beans and
toast every day this sounds depressingly
familiar sarah worries about her and
tells her to eat well-cooked food but
carly is clearly not interested in
talking she answers in single words
mostly because it is overwhelming to
talk to her mother knowing that she will
die one of these days sarah apologizes
for disturbing her and claims that she
misses her but carly hangs up the call
before she can finish sarah gets
emotional after the call so she brings
out her music player to help her calm
down but to her misfortune she
accidentally drops it for some seconds
she loses her calm and screams in
frustration her screams invite a flock
of birds towards her which instantly
cheers her mood she waves her hands
around happily in between them dave
misses his wife dearly and resorts to
alcoholism to get rid of the pain one
night it starts to rain heavily although
sarah is wearing thick clothes they are
not enough to keep her warm she misses
her family but can do nothing about it
she somehow survives the night holding
herself to keep warm the following day
she reaches higher in the sky and now
requires an oxygen mask to survive
she removes the mask and calls her
husband
dave runs to the phone and asks her if
she is doing well carly also comes
running worried about her mother sarah
tells carly that even if she fails her
exams she is very proud of her and will
always love her dave repeatedly asks her
to put the oxygen mask back on but she
refuses instead she asks them to stand
away from the hole in the ceiling
seconds later a bag falls through it the
two register that sarah has decided to
stop holding onto her life carly falls
to the floor and hugs the bag begging
for her mother to return as the sun
rises sarah flies faster into the sky
with a smile on her face she tells her
husband that she loves him and puts the
phone down
a while later it falls through the
ceiling the father and the daughter hold
each other and cry mourning sarah's
death it is now a few weeks after the
incident the family has repaired the
ceiling carly prepares tea and breakfast
for both of them and studies hard for
her finals dave notices a change in her
behavior after sarah's death the movie
ends as they eat the meal in silence
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching